uh so
uh you know it's interesting we're gonna
talk about french of course and we we
always begin in english and then we go
over some
lesson uh when you share your screen
with us
but i was just thinking today you know
there's all this talk about opening up
schools
and universities
and how much should be done online or
remotely and how much needs to be done
in the classroom and this kind of thing
and so i was just thinking about how the
world of learning has changed
when i see my wife for example the
amount of things that she learns on
youtube
whether it be making sourdough bread or
golf or music
or you know if i have a coffee maker and
it's
some something is flashing clean it or
whatever and i don't know how to clean
it i go to youtube
uh so many things now that we are able
to learn
uh on our own as long as we're curious
and and know what it is we want to learn
and so i was thinking you know that also
applies to languages like
used to be that that the teacher had
this mystery like i know french so you
don't know french i know french so i'm
going to give you you know drip by drip
all my knowledge on french
whereas now you don't need that i can
look anything up
assuming i want to learn the language
now of course a lot of kids in school
don't want to learn anything so you
absolutely need the teacher to crack the
whip or somehow it you know induce them
to want to learn something but but for
university students if they actually
know what they want to learn
they can go find it so i think to that
extent the world has changed quite a bit
absolutely so yeah i couldn't agree more
there's uh there's a running joke with
me and my friends that there it's uh
you know really expensive uh state
schools and universities and ivy league
schools and then there's youtube
university exactly oh good i'm i i just
halted notifications on slack there but
yeah i think that's really important i
saw where uh now we're wandering off the
subject but it doesn't matter uh because
it has to do with language learning like
i have learned so many languages on my
own using link of course but because i'm
curious because i and and i get help
from the community as to where to find
resources and stuff like this but i look
up what i need to look up romanian
grammar or or you know arabic verbs it's
all there
i don't need a teacher to give it to me
and if i had gone to say
ubc here university of british columbia
to learn russian i still wouldn't speak
russian uh they
you know and and yet i've done 10
languages and i've and i've listened to
audiobooks on the history of russia
ukraine poland and i've read books and
stuff like that you can learn so much
more on your own
without waiting for the teacher to to
tell you what to do
i think the world has changed yeah and
and you so then you see harvard that's
going to charge 50 000 for online
courses in other words they're not going
to reduce the price
right so
and if they have a wonderful teacher
professor there he or she
can access the world
not limited to the 200 people you can
cram into a into a lecture hall like
something absolutely
yeah the world is completely shifting
and um
and
to your point too about you know you you
have to be um
you have to want to learn right and
this is a this is a reoccurring theme
lately in my life
um there's two different important
aspects to doing anything
um learning being one of them
and one is your your capability
but the one that comes before that is
your willingness
and they're independent of one another
um but combined you know they're gonna
make that that magic equation uh if you
have them both to be able to um to
acquire a new skill or to level up in
your career or whatever it is and but
usually the willingness has to come
first right because no matter how
capable you are of doing something which
everyone's capable of learning a
language right
but they have to also be willing to do
that and that's why you know the
internet um can be this like magical
resource for people but it could also be
just a bunch of noise it depends on how
you use the tool
absolutely and you know i think yeah
obviously not everyone is going to learn
to run 100 yards as you know or 100
meters or whatever it is
there's a big difference in ability
there but when it comes to learning
languages there are differences in
ability and obviously people have
learned more than one language have a
big advantage but that difference is not
so great it's it's the willingness
the willingness you know the desire the
confidence the interest
that's by far the biggest factor
anyway now that we've covered all that
uh philosophy
how's your french
going and so therefore no where i was
leading with that is so so really the
willingness the curiosity has to be the
driver so i don't want to say today
we're going to do this objective or
today we're going to do the future
tension the conditional tense because
you may not be ready for that you may
not want that that may be
something you're not interested in right
now so i prefer
to do what we've been doing go through
some texts and then if you have specific
issues that you what you could google
for but i since i happen to have you
know learned a bit of french if i can
answer those questions i will if i don't
answer them or if it's it's before next
week you can also look them up
but but the driver has to be the learner
not the teacher
in my opinion
so completely agree
okay so let's uh let's uh and one more
general philosophy
thing
i i do believe in the many stories
so
i think very often so
you know if we're talking about school
children they don't know what to go
looking for so the teacher has to
suggest do this do that do something
else
in language learning i think to some
extent the teacher can at least at an
initial stage suggest this might be good
for you or
if you don't know where if you're
interested in music or in in you know
whatever right
film of this yeah you might be able to
find it here but i do believe that the
uh that the many stories i've i've found
that they're not only a good place to
break into the language but they remain
sort of i call them like the fitness
they're the language gym
because i always go back to them and and
i always discover new things and i'm
just training training training in the
the basic verbs and the basic structures
of the language then i get bored and i
go charge off and and explore something
which is genuinely interesting to me and
i'm gathering you know more words and
stuff but then i come back to the to the
mini stories even though i i have no
more blue words there and i do them
again and again and i listen to them so
often that that gives me that the base
from which i can start expressing myself
so i just would recommend that you you
you stay with the many stories and and
do listen to them a lot because it it
tends to groove certain language habits
um but you get tired after a while
yeah exactly i'm already seeing that
happening um with the mini stories and i
haven't um proceeded um you and i were
originally thinking we were going to
focus mostly on mini stories for this
series and then we've kind of branched
off into other content that i've uh
explored so um
i
have i think i've now gone through like
nine of them so it's like really slow
you know you could say but um i continue
to listen back to them i have them on my
playlist and i listen to them and
exactly what you described is happening
to me i'm
um
in some ways i'm just really
internalizing the sentence structure and
the the pronunciations
um but i'm then every once in a while i
noticed something different
and then i noticed i i mean this
happened to me in the last couple of
weeks that i'm starting to just
understand it in french instead of just
trying to translate back and forth
between my mind like oh this equals that
right um but i'm loving having the
variety too like that's keeping me
like able to come back to the many
stories that i have the
this music and the
liberty plans and i have this other
inner french videos that i've been
watching so it's a nice combination that
keeps me interested no matter what you
know what i mean exactly yeah absolutely
and i think first of all i i often
repeat what manfred spitzer said you
know we need repetition and we need
novelty
and i think the fact that you're curious
and that you have these other interests
and you're exploring i mean that's a
good thing
because i think there is a danger if you
only do the many stories you can get
again and anything we only do something
of we yeah we can get in a run
[Music]
you